la construction du nouveau centre
hospitalier de québec illustre
parfaitement ce qu'a connu le réseau de
la santé a l'air dix ministres guettant
bahreïn que plusieurs surnomment
d'ailleurs le bulldozers en quatre ans
il a mis plusieurs réformes en chantier
n'hésitant pas à raser christine ou bien
vous allez dans notre direction
ou bien vous y est les pauvres mais si
vous vouliez à l'époque mais là il va y
avoir des conseils le beurre l'argent du
beurre la vache à lait tient la ferme on
peut pas tout avoir dans la vie j'ai
forcé les gens à changer d'approché un
moment donné il faut il prendre des
décisions dès les premiers mois de son
mandat guettant baril donnent le ton
avec le projet de loi disent l'objectif
abolir les agences de santé et fusionner
les 180 deux centres de santé et de
services sociaux environ 6000 cadre
perdre leur emploi
ce projet de loi est irrecevable c'est
pathétique quand on y pense tout le
temps après il est confronté à sa
première crise de leadership alors que
le directeur général et plusieurs
membres du conseil d'administration du
chum démissionnent en bloc pour dénoncer
l'ingérence et l'abus de pouvoir du
ministre
j'ai pris une décision qui est basé sur
mes valeurs mon intégrité
si c'est pas mon devoir d'intervenir je
suis moi quelle forme on roule il réussi
à dénouer l'impasse
mais les hostilités reprennent avec les
médecins cette fois de budget arrive
rien qui remplace et dans les hôpitaux
présentement pourquoi ce qui s'engage
quant à garantir ces axes l on n'a pas
fait un paul aujourd'hui l'apport un
seul bon
tous les québécois aient accès à un
médecin de famille le ministre impose
des quotas de patients aux
omnipraticiens avec des sanctions
financières en cas d'échec des quotas
qui seront finalement abandonné nous
avons proposé des solutions pour
améliorer l'accessibilité solution qui
ont obtenu un engagement clair des
médecins de famille la fédération des
médecins omnipraticiens s'est engagé à
respecter une cible au 31 décembre 2007
85 % des québécois devait avoir accès à
un médecin de famille
à quelques mois de l'échéance le
ministre a accepté de changer les règles
pour atteindre l'objectif plus
facilement mais il ne sera pas atteint à
la date prévue jeudi courage en trouve
le programme air miles and should en
font la magie toi s'appelle médicaments
et puis t'as pas de doute c'est quoi en
2008 des milliers de patients sont
inscrits au guichet d'accès mais n'ont
toujours pas obtenu leur premier rendez
vous et pendant ce temps avec les
médecins spécialistes
le ton monte guetta var est écarté des
négociations visant rattrapage salarial
slip ou du nouvel argent sur trois pages
qui a été fait au cours des dernières
années le gouvernement signe une entente
de huit ans avec la fédération des
médecins spécialistes
il accorde 2 milliards de dollars en
échange de garanties pour assurer les
services dans les hôpitaux
autrement dit impatient qui n'arrive pas
à voir un médecin lorsqu'ils arrivent
ici ça ne doit plus arriver
pourquoi ont-ils cédé ce qui est
inacceptable c'est que les médecins
spécialistes du québec gagnent plus que
les médecins spécialistes l'ontario qui
reste valable même au sein de la
fédération des médecins spécialistes le
lien confiance semble s'effriter
l'entente est loin de faire l'unanimité
le première main qui arrête de dire que
sa réforme est une réussite sur les
réseaux sociaux une infirmière à bout de
souffle lance un cri du coeur et
provoque une véritable avalanche de
témoignages parmi ses collègues on est
épuisé ça va de pire en pire
ça s'est vraiment dégradée
d'effectifs est récurrent pour que ça
change le c'est sûr que toutes les infos
des infirmières dénonce les heures
supplémentaires obligatoires et
organisent des sit in pour manifester
contre la surcharge de travail et des
infirmières qui sont entrés nous appelés
en nous disant je vais motos des noms
aussi j'veux pas capable de suivre mes
obligations professionnelles
j'aimerais qu'elle me dise à moi à nous
ce qu'elle propose qu'on fasse de plus
parce qu'on a signé avec elle des temps
barrette s'engage à mettre sur pied des
projets visant à trouver le ratio idéal
de patients pour chaque infirmière la
page des médecins et tourner la page qui
est devant nous est celle des
infirmières
réformer des structures et réorganiser
le travail ça nécessite des
installations plus modernes
en plus de gérer le déménagement du cuse
mais du chum à montréal le ministre a
lancé deux importants projets de
modernisation celui de la cité de la
santé à laval et celui de l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont qui est évalué à
presque 2 milliards de dollars j'ai pris
ce qu'on doive se battre pour recevoir
des bains ou des douches supplémentaires
je pense que la population s'est
exprimée assez clairement
interpellé par des résidents ch et celle
des ghettos barrette premier un deuxième
but par semaine une promesse qui peine à
se réaliser faute de main d'oeuvre
terminé aussi les patates en poudre le
ministre organise une dégustation durant
laquelle il annonce que les menus de
tous les établissements vont changer
pour le meilleur
mais bon
m
excellent
les surplus budgétaires lui permettre
d'annoncer la rénovation de plusieurs ch
et celle d'eads amorcer le virage des
soins à domicile
la nouvelle priorité de gaétan barrette
parallèlement il multiplie la création
de super clinique et de gmf partout en
province
tous ces investissements ont contribué à
réduire le temps d'attenté sur civière
dans les urgences depuis trois ans mais
il y a peu ou pas d'amélioration dans
les salles d'attentes
[Musique]